straight up um yo you and amber man I
feel like you guys are like the perfect
like example of people who you know
obviously relationships don't work out
but you raised your son together and
support each other yeah man like like
how hard is that to cuz cuz yo man I
mean I I've been through it with my baby
mama you know what I'm saying and it's
not always it's not always peachy you
know what I'm saying but she's always
coming like you guys always got each
other's back you know I'm saying it's
not hard man i got i love amber like I'm
always gonna love her and I got her back
she got mine and when that's what it all
boils down to it and that's it did you
see this photo her and Kim posted yeah
all right camera cause she they talked
actually on the phone and me a actually
talked that everything's cool so it's
all straight that's good to hear man cuz
obviously I'm friends with you and and
and will and Kanye is one of my favorite
rappers so it's like Jesus but you know
sometimes it's just stuff you can't
violate women and I just feel like you
know well I mean we've been we've it
cool for a really long time you know me
personally yeah so at the end of the day
meet saying that everything is all good
it shouldn't be a surprise